vous remercie votre altesse royale de
nous recevoir chez vous à buckingham
palace vous lancer une campagne pour
sauvegarder la planète pour une
stratégie la de l'avenir de la vie à
votre avis quelle est la principale
l'urgence aujourd'hui est la principale
priorité c'est la dégradation de leur
environnement naturel partout dans le
monde de ce tous les espèces sauvages
bien d'être mexique on n y est on prend
beaucoup trop d arbres on utilise
beaucoup trop d'idées dépassant de la
mer il ya des désirs désertification par
tous les bleus populations du monde
augmente chaque année alors s'il ya
beaucoup de raisons pour essayer
d'arrêter cette dégradation et vous avez
l'impression votre altesse royale que on
comprend un peu plus qu'avant
je crois oui oui de l'enfance de
l'information se diffuse partout il ya
maintenant pas d' excuses pour les pour
les gens les administrateurs les
professionnels les politiciens ils ont
pas d'exclu maintenant de par comprendre
parce qu'on a pas parlé de ça pour
tellement de temps et du chaque jour on
parle de ça ailleurs il ya tant d
organisation qui qui promettent le bleu
sauvegarder la nature et le tas de la
terre lancent ils ont vraiment il doit
savoir s'ils peuvent lire s'ils peuvent
voir la télévision vous vous sentez
récompensés dans les efforts que vous
avez fait depuis des années je sais pas
si récompensé parce que justement on a
on n'a pas beaucoup gagné peut-être on a
arrêté le le
des relations mais le déclin mais on n'a
pas vraiment donc pas encore on n'a pas
fait de progrès vrai votre altesse
royale les superpuissances se prononce
en ce moment en faveur d'un désarmement
et vous même vous demander dans votre
dans votre brochure une réduction des
crédits militaires c'est important c'est
pas les grandes armes keqiang qui ont
détruit l'environnement ce sont les gens
avec des petites armes qui il ya des
endroits dans par exemple dans un grand
bol de candy en match oui oui on en a
fait de l'aide de la guerre pendant que
naturellement il n'y a pas de la
yougoslavie yalgo sa vie dans tous les
endroits en fait il ya des combats
civile
alors il n'y a pas de ne pas sauvegarder
la nature dans ces langues sans
condition est ce qu'il y à des espèces
qu'il faut protéger en priorité ou que
vous seul vous aimeriez protéger en
priorité
non je crois pas parce que c'est pas ça
c'est pas la question des espèces cette
question des endroits où les espèces
peuvent vivre mon patron doit protéger
les habitats il ya naturellement des ddd
facteurs par exemple les les rhinos en a
besoin on aime beaucoup les candidats
comme décor et il y a beaucoup de
braconnage
alors ça on doit contrôler parce que
sans ça on va on va enlever cette espèce
qui t'a fait c'est la même chose avec
mon c'est pas tellement dangereux avec
les éléphants mais il ya des endroits
dans l'afrique du nord où les éléphants
sont presque disparu mais dans le sud il
ya presque trop les audois n'est pas
impossible
il ya beaucoup d'autres et qu'est ce
qu'on fait dans le jeu on doit les tuer
oui parce qu'il peut pas soutenir une
population de par exemple au zimbabwe
ils ont une population de 60 me il croit
que dans les endroits protégés et dans
les endroits où les éléphants peut
sortir ils peuvent soutenir à peu près
40 milles
c'est à dire que les gens ne savent pas
que les éléphants consomme énormément et
qui dévastent non leur leur habitat demi
mais la sa habitat et par conséquent au
delà d'un certain nombre d'éléphants
c'est exactement le même principe pour
les gens seulement que notre région
protégée pour nous c'est la terre au
caire c'est le principe c'est exactement
le même
est-ce que vous votre altesse royale
vous condamner toutes les formes de
chasse non pourquoi je demande vous vous
défendez l'environnement sauvegarder les
espèces on se dit pourquoi pas ce que
l'on mange de boeuf et de mouton dans la
presse et de boutons pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas manger dessert ou des deux
lapins ou quoi mais vous comprenez qu'on
puisse chasser certaines espèces
mais pourquoi pas seulement on doit pas
en danger l'espèce en totale ça c'est
l'important on doit toujours on peut
utiliser le surplus sens humble avis va
arrêter tout à fait et pour la pêche
c'est la même chose d'absolument et en
ce moment est ce qu'il ne faut pas
empêcher le pillage des océans oui il ya
des moyens techniques considérables mais
la difficulté est là c'est le
les haussiers centrales sont pas
protégés ils sont pas la propriété de
personne alors tout le monde peut
rentrer il penser ce qu'il veut alors
c'est ça on va en bas le vide est
demandé aux vans le bel vidéo le piller
tout à fait dans quelques années
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme bien comme
patrimoine des hommes assure garder en
priorité la diversité biologique
alors tous parce que nous sommes tous la
vie du monde ce qu il existe autour du
monde alors c'est une commune une poêle
tout autour alors mais on peut pas
enlever des pièces ça existe ensemble on
peut pas dire par exemple que si on
enlève les mains ce ça va c'est très
bien pour pour quelqu'un dont les pieds
c'est beaucoup plus difficile pour elle
si encore on enlève on enlève on enlève
jusqu'au square n'a seulement la tête on
est mort si ce qui arrive à la terre oui
c'est ce que les harry potter on enlève
tout le temps des pièces et le récent
traité qui a été signé pour sauvegarder
pendant 50 ans l'antarctique c'est une
bonne chose votre avis votre altesse
royale oui pourquoi seulement 50 ans
pour mieux plus long que ça et on doit
on doit protéger aussi tout autour la
mer tout autour je ne sais pas protégés
ils n'ont pas assez
c'est à dire que c'est un premier pas
ses espérances
d'où vient votre intérêt pour l'écologie
non parce que quand j'étais petit
j'étais plus jeune j'ai habité dans la
compagnie après des années j'ai vu qu'il
y à des changements tout le temps chaque
année on n'a pas vu cet oiseau par
exemple est pas arrivés cette année
qu'est ce qui passait notre
on a vu que les les villes sagan des
tout le temps les forêts disparaissent
chaque arabe avec le passé le passage du
temps on voit toujours que c'est
différent et c'est toujours pire et sans
être indiscret sa majesté la reine
soutient l'action que vous menez dans
pour ce qui concerne ce père ne vous
pourquoi pas c'est pas tellement elle
croit elle aussi que c'est un grand défi
des années qui viennent dont sûrement
oui est ce qu'aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de gens n'ont pas la tentation de
placer avant les droits de l'homme les
droits de la nature il ya pas des droits
il ya des responsabilités je sais c'est
pas des droits que nous nous avons c'est
pas seulement une responsabilité pour la
nature c'est une responsabilité pour
l'avenir du de l'humanité en totale
parce que nous avons maintenant le le
possibilité de décider pour l'avenir des
deux des gens qui vont arriver après
nous ici nous faisons pas les décisions
correctes
il n'y aura pas d'avenir pour les autres
et la planète si elle était sauvée elle
ne serait pas trop triste on ne
s'ennuierait pas dans une planète idéale
on se serre sera jamais idéal mais nous
sommes dans un moment de crise je pense
parce que nous avons maintenant la
possibilité de changer le futur l'avenir
et si on ne fait rien ce sera horrible
vraiment pour les pour les luminaires
l'humanité dont 50 ans par exemple mais
votre altesse royale vous dites on est
dans une situation de crise c'est vrai
mais ce qu'en même temps on n'est pas
dans une situation qui permet de
résoudre les crises on voit ce qui se
passe quand trop tard je suis content
que je suis ici à alger que je suis
pourquoi
parce que ce sera beaucoup plus
difficile dans quelques années
oui mais avec le mouvement qui a
commencé peut-être la prise de peut-être
jeu se développe
peut-être grâce aussi à des actions
semblables mais peut-être
[Musique]